seit gestern durchsuchen ermittler einen
kleingarten bei hannover zwei bagger und
auch spürhunde sind dafür im einsatz
die staatsanwaltschaft braunschweig
bestätigt dass diese durchsuchung in
zusammenhang mit der vermissten maddie
stehen am stadtrand der
niedersächsischen landeshauptstadt setzt
die polizei bei grabungsarbeiten ihre
grabungsarbeiten in einem kleingarten
fort seit gestern laufen diese bereits
unter dem fundament resten fanden die
beamten einen verborgenen kellerraum der
zu dem ehemaligen garten haus gehört
haben soll darüber und was die ermittler
dort aber fanden gibt es bisher keine
weiteren auskünfte
wir wollen jetzt aber auch noch einmal
genauer schauen wo sich das
durchsuchungs gebiet befindet die
gartenparzelle bei setzte ist nur wenige
kilometer von bse ehemaligen wohnort in
hannover entfernt bei der fläche handelt
es sich offiziell um grabeland dort sind
einzelne parzellen pächter die
allerdings nicht in einer art neue art
verein organisiert sind
die fläche zwischen der b 441 und dem
mittellandkanal beherbergt eine handvoll
dieser gärten wasser gibt es dort nicht
und man darf dort auch nicht wohnen
wenn man die fläche aufgibt muss man
seine laube zurückbauen interessant
genau das soll christian b auch getan
haben und mein kollege daniel
puskepeleitis ist jetzt für uns dort vor
ort bei dieser kleingartenanlage daniel
sag uns was kam es uns über den neuesten
ermittlungsstand sagen ja also den
ganzen tag der zweite tag in folge wurde
hier gebaggert es wurde noch mal die
hunde eingesetzt die spürhunde
es ist alles abgeräumt man kann nicht
richtig sehen was die ermittler
möglicherweise gefunden haben
zwischendurch wurden containerweise
bauschutt und grünzeug abtransportiert
gefunden wurde dann am ende tatsächlich
ein keller
das ist nicht ungewöhnlich in
kleingärten diesen alters früher auch in
der nachkriegszeit habe ein häufiger
keller angelegt so war es auch hier als
die parzelle aufgegeben wurde wurde die
laube zurück barock der keller aber
blieb ja es ist fast alles abgesperrt
man kann nichts von den ermittlungen
sehen nun gibt es auch ein flugverbot
vom bka über dieser stelle was kannst du
uns da zu sagen
es scheint tatsächlich ein flugverbot zu
geben wobei die frage ist wann das
verhängt wurde drohen dürfen hier
tatsächlich seit gestern schon nicht
mehr aufsteigen aber ab nachmittag wurde
auch der gesamte luftraum gesperrt
wahrscheinlich wollen die ermittler
verhindern um jeden preis verhindern
dass aufnahmen von oben gemacht werden
es läuft alles sehr im verborgenen und
auch spürhunde sind im einsatz gibt es
dazu informationen nach was genau sie
suchen
nein die polizei sagt dazu nichts
es ist alles mögliche denkbar dass
können natürlich leichenspürhunde sein
das können aber natürlich auch spürhunde
seien die abgerichtet sind auf
datenträger oder handys oder sonstiges
weiter tage waren die hunde hier die
hunde sind jetzt mittlerweile schon weg
und so wie es ausschaut nach unseren
informationen sollen möglicherweise auch
die arbeiten die sucharbeiten heute noch
eingestellt werden